und zwar dass man einfach generell in qs
g und den sg die angel auch ohne glitsch
also dass man den glitch deaktiviert und
die angel auf 20 oder noch mal 10 15
uses limitiert weil so ist es wirklich
viel zu krass guckt euch das an services
und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
folge heute spielen wir minecraft quick
survival games und wir machen heute
einfach mal ein umgekehrtes kiel
was soll das jetzt bedeutet fragt ihr
euch sicher folgendes erst mal dass ich
sterbe rückert bitte nicht boxen okay
das ist unrealistisch dass ich überlebe
ohne waffe denn da hat man ganz ganz
schlechte chancen die die cops kann man
nicht abbauen ohne schwert bzw es dauert
einfach zu lange
umgekehrt ist juni heißt normalerweise
büro kaiserswerth ja komm hoch kochten
hoch dann kriegst eine in die fresse mit
dem bogen umgekehrt ist juni heißt leute
ganz einfach
normalerweise ist die amazone youtuber
stellt sagt gibt euch die aufforderung
fragen zu stellen ihr stellt die fragen
werden beantwortet umgekehrt ist juni
heißt dass ich also dass der youtuber
die frage gestellt und das glück bitte
mal kein tier präzis als orthopäde hat
aber schon gut gefressen
wo volvo oder immer noch kommt ihm der
test aber wir haben zuletzt ausgezehrt
es regel geht nicht für die chest weil
es ja kein eis mehr und meine erste
frage an euch in diesem umgekehrten juni
ist ganz einfach aber eigentlich auch
sehr sehr ungewöhnlich
warum schaut ihr meine videos was
gefällt euch daran schreibt das einfach
mal in die kommentare
nehmt euch vielleicht kurzzeit 45
minuten manche auch drei manche manche
nehmen sich auf sein pech war nämlich
einfach kurzzeit wenn ihr euch zeit
nehmen müsst dafür müsst jetzt nicht
sofort was in die kommentare schreiben
überlegt euch und wenn euch was einfällt
wohl sagt ihr habt daran liegts okay zum
beispiel daran dass ich so gerne kids
abstauber dann schreibe es in die
kommentare
so interessiert mich mega interessieren
bottega clean up ist reha-klinik in
israel frisst es ist der letzte ball
gewonnen alter aber richtig 50 sekunden
bevor es bestand hätte am 6
danke rudi danke bruder ist nämlich hat
ein bruder oder der richter hat der
helmut mit dem magischen hand vision
habe ich uns direkt in die nächste runde
befördert es funktioniere das gut aber
ich bin schon ein bisschen magischen
stichwort magisch leute wow lauf lauf
lauf lauf lauf okay das mit kleiner
spaziergang jetzt spricht daher wie
ausgestorben ist er gestalte sich
ausgeloggt die konnte der da sterben
das irgendwo irgendwas passt halt so
aufgeregt darüber dass sich
heruntergesprungen bin dass sie sich
selbst entzwei gerissen hat wie das ok
schließen
ich glaub ich was ich machen wollte mag
ich schaue in den letzten tagen echt
echt viel supernatural schreibt man die
kommentare wenn die die serie auch kennt
okay das ist frage 2 im umgekehrten kimi
kennt ihr supernatural und wenn ja
schaut ihr es auch schreibt mir das mal
die kommentare
das würde mich mal interessieren sondern
könnt euch eine hoch oder abstrakte geht
weg würde ich sagen hinterher
da kommt einer oder ja egal wir machen
das mal dass die zweite frage schau dir
auch supernatural
aber nein aber nicht machen
macht es nicht egal dass wir nicht so
cool von dir mich jetzt hier so
anzugreifen so ganz hinterrücks tag 13
euro häufig so komisch und lag man nicht
so alt sehr gemein zu gefährlich meinen
junge was du daraus dass der download
läuft einfach unter die libro er läuft
voll in das tnt ist es dann ernst gibt
ihn einfach gar nicht er wird auch
glaube ich selbst wissen attackiert ich
sollte noch einer
ich weiß es nicht irgendwas passiert
darum was passiert da was passiert da
er springt runter okay er ist ganz große
sprung er springt hinterher achter ist
wasser das wusste ich erst mal okay gut
wieder was gelernt die idee kein plan
laster was aber ich habe keinen plan
das wasser war es frisst mein bogen
amador junge wir haben schon darüber
geschafft und jetzt zack zack zack zack
zack oder injoy schwer kommende oder das
goldtrikot sg schon länger wenig dumm
oder ein online ohne einwohner und ein
box ich mal gegenseitig damit der box
solchen tieres so iris goller
vollgefressen jetzt komplettiert
dankeschön dankeschön dankeschön heute
alter ok nächste runde
keller leer
3 203 diesmal hat es auch ohne kampf
zwischen kloppich hell wie kann es sein
wie kann das auch eine handtaschen
klappt ich hab das nicht in hand gericht
gewaschen ja ja leute aber nicht
gewischt
die wm jetzt nicht so bewusst wir müssen
aufpassen vielleicht erstmal klienten
damit wir unser erstes rüstungsteile
unsere gäste sorgen könnte aber es ist
so ok seine eisen chest hab ich gesehen
und sie mal kurz ein ruhiges fleckchen
suchen und das thema anzuziehen hier ein
bogen auch sehr gut schön passt und das
ist schon der erste täter ist okay da
muss jetzt aufpassen
ja der könnte nämlich wo ja nee nee nee
nee nee
der hat mir bis zu widmen das wird nix
wird zunächst müssen uns was neues
suchen eine neue ansprechen komme ich
möchte ist er hat seine rüstung aus
gehabt das heißt jetzt richtig
angekommen konnte sie jetzt gerade
anziehen
danke für die range auf jeden fall ist
das theater place man da nicht schlecht
gemacht
plötzlich aber da kommt meine maus ist
crazy achtet man aber man muss man auch
blocken wenn man so derbe viel schaden
krieg zum fall läuft ein bisschen das
klassische links rechts musste jetzt
auch dass die andere ist so unnötig
bitte gar leute ganz ehrlich was ich
euch noch fragen wollte was haltet ihr
von meinem vorschlag den ich schon
länger mal bisschen ausgearbeitet mir
überlegt herausgeholt hat und zwar dass
man einfach generell in qst und den sg
die angel auch ohne glitsch also dass
man den glitch deaktiviert und die angel
auf 20 oder einmal 10 15 uses limitiert
weil so ist es wirklich viel zu krass
guckt euch das an das ist einfach immer
das gleiche dieser heutige an spam und
die leute brauchen überhaupt keins
kinder können die ganze zeit von einbeck
halten und es ist schwer ist jetzt
schwierig auszuweichen vor allem wenn
man so eine erbärmliche range of wie ich
aber jetzt hier könnt ihr mit geben das
finde ich echt unnötig also es war nicht
der sinn der sache
genau da wird man nämlich davon hinten
angegriffen das kann es auch nicht sein
es kann einfach nicht sein alter
das kann es einfach nicht sein das ist
roddick man das ist echt roddick
wirklich der runde team und jetzt werden
wir noch mal probieren ihr wissen was zu
reißen
jawoll alter erste kiste einfach nur
gold bugs effekt auf jeden fall schon
mal gut an
hier hätten es noch eine ohne gold
leggins waffen sind mir heute vielleicht
nicht gegönnt
hier wie die cios doch der ist auch ein
bisschen mehr stoff zum beispiel mal ein
brot bleiben einfach aus prinzip jetzt
vielleicht sehr schön danke chester 20
gold aber besser als nichts sagt so
durch mal das machen aber die armut kurz
mal anziehen hier schon was nee nee da
war feuer drin 122 fall schon mal gut so
sonst können wir das sommer drin lassen
wird weiter im text ja leute eine frage
doch eine frage möchte ich noch
unbedingt stellen diesen keeway wie
gesagt alle fragen gerne mit einem
kommentar beantworten weil ein kommentar
unten wo kommt der kommentar hin es du
weißt es nicht okay ich beantworte es
dir schreibe es in die kommentare rein
aber nicht meinen namen sondern die
antwort wird er okay eisenstein schwert
sehr schönes upgrade sehr schön das
upgrade für dieses upgrade man bei
mercedes benz etwa 10.000 euro gezahlt
hier im kurs gibt es umsonst und damit
ja ist nice nice wir dürfen das dürfen
wir anziehen denn die ihr wisst bescheid
ok quartier ein bisschen klein machen
perfekt eigentlich nette runde dahin ist
der nächste gegner sieht es bei dir aus
die ages orlac nicht mal
aber die first in first minute jetzt
muss ich aufpassen
er ist okay jetzt kann ich ein bisschen
es gebe noch mehr pfeile 37 an der zahl
könnten jetzt theoretisch mal überlegen
unser inventar hier so ein bisschen
auszumisten kurs geht den wenigstens
dabei ist die die items sind eigentlich
relativ uniform also eigentlich mal
relativ gleich es gibt nicht so eine
große vielfalt geteilt schwerter
rüstungen bogen eine feile tnt essen und
mein gold apfel das ist alles aber
anders als in 2d gamescom jetzt nichts
kräften oder so sonst wäre es ja nicht
so quick aber deswegen braucht man nicht
so viele items deswegen kann man ja
schön sauber machen
ja genau lautet die letzte frage stellen
wollte ich glaube dass krankenhäuser
gegangen ist
welche musik hört ihr eigentlich so als
ich persönlich er ist in gold of it init
mai goldeck okay dann schießt man die
pfeile wo man es verstehen die verbinden
dosenöffner wie ist die lage bei dir ja
ich würde gerne meine meine
verbundenheit mit einem pfeil in dein
gesicht signalisieren demonstrieren und
intuitiven meditieren yanar ist die
wolga den anderen okay ich hab mich
kennt der weiß dass man das mal den
start hier liegen kommt dass man jetzt
dafür liegen die ganz neues von ihr
anliegen kommt es gedauert jetzt ist
leichter und du bist nicht du bist dann
hast du vergessen schöne bogen schott
endlich fertig ist es fertig halbes herz
lauf doch noch mal neue junge läuft doch
mal ein halbes herz der zwei herzen
alter ein schöner kampf würde ich sagen
dann belasten erstmal dabei für heute
gerne die antworten auf die fertig
gestellt hat man diesen umgekehrten kyu
mal in die kommentare schreiben
ich lese die kommentare und antwortet
dann auch gerne
wir sind im nächsten video wieder haut
rein macht's gut und ja